foreign
in Kansas City what's up Leanne
hey how's it going I'm good how are you
I'm doing well thanks for taking my call
of course what's up
so
um I bottom line is yeah just say
whatever it is just say it I I don't
trust my husband and I don't I don't
know how to trust him
okay how did he lose trust with you
I mean he likes to lie I was gonna say
your your language is somebody who is so
gaslit like you've got third degree
burns
he tells half tree he's a liar let's
start with that okay keep going yeah
what does he lie about I mean like small
things but also really big things like
to him it's small but like two but we
can't make it to
um somebody's birthday party and he
thinks he needs to come up with like an
elaborate really deep reason why we
don't need to be there and I'm like we
we're not going because whatever I mean
we don't want to go wrong reason right
we don't want to go or or not that but
he'll do that and then he will lie about
big things too like
I mean I could think of a million things
but like
okay
um we had to get rid of a cat that we
had okay and this is this feels so dumb
saying this because this is how dumb the
situation is but we had to get rid of
this cat because he wasn't taking care
of it when I was gone which again sounds
dumb but the reason he told everybody
else was because this cat got sick and
um we couldn't take care of it anymore
and that just wasn't the reason and I'm
like you you were you were being
irresponsible
that's why we had to get rid of it it's
like clearly he's uncomfortable with
these things but after so long I I just
can't trust him and then smaller things
like getting into
onto the field at football games like he
thinks that's so great but he's like
he's lying about it by printing off fake
passes
as a grown man to get onto the field at
a football game and I just find it so
childish and embarrassing and after now
10 years of marriage like I
all those small eyes build up over time
I just
I don't trust them uh what else does
so I hear you 100 percent
there's something else what is it
I
I don't I don't know like like there's
something sitting but has he cheated on
you
no
I mean there was there was a long period
of time where he just wouldn't have sex
with me and it hurts so much and he just
kept saying it was because he you know
medication or
um
yeah mostly just medication or he was
like I think I'm asexual and I'm like
what that doesn't make any sense and I
will like the entire time
for like this three year period I really
I just questioned it three years
three years
wow
and
I do y'all share your money
yes
well I mean
yes but there's
um there's money that I don't see fully
I guess
so here's the deal
it happens
um you you've run into an old college
friend who used to be big and they lost
a bunch of weight you haven't seen them
in a few years and it's like whoa it
looks it's so dramatic
and they it feels so good but for them
they know it's dramatic they see the
number on the scale but to them it
happened every day
just like a quarter of a pound here half
of a pound here gain a pound back lose
one and a half pounds right and that
happened over the period of a couple of
years and so it's very gradual
and suddenly they're a totally different
person when you walk in right
yeah
what's happened over the last 10 years
is
you have gradually
grain by grain of sand lost your footing
on reality
your husband lies about everything
and he's lying about big stuff too and
you know it
and my guess is not only is he great at
lying and cutting corners and cheating
he's living in an ALT reality right he
lives in a world that the rules don't
apply to him reality doesn't apply to
him and everyone else is stupider than
me
from the guy the poor volunteer at the
high school football game to my boss to
the people who took my cat to my wife
they're all dumber than me I'm running a
scam on all of them
and what happens when that happens over
time without the the big bludgeon of you
found pictures of him with somebody else
right there's that
but that's not what happened here this
was just Pebble by Pebble by Pebble and
suddenly over time you the person you
trust the least is Leanne
you think you're crazy
yeah
you're not crazy
you're not crazy
and I'm like
the heartbreaking thing here is
um
you've been being dragged underwater for
a long time and you keep wondering why
you can't find your footing as though
it's your fault
yeah so here's the here's the path out
and it's not a pleasant one okay
okay it's sitting with somebody who you
know and love and trust and who actually
knows this dude knows the whole story
knows everything because because my I I
almost guarantee in the in the core of
my being I know
that if you and I sat here and peeled
back the layers on this there is some
bad stuff
yeah is that fair
yeah
this type of behavior in this type of
pattern hasn't happened this long
without there being some big stuff that
you simply put hardwood floors over
because you couldn't bear to look at it
or see or feel it and so this sits with
you sitting with somebody else if you
don't have a close close friend that
knows everything or a sister or a cousin
that knows everything you go get a
counselor but you've got to come up with
your no more list
and you're gonna have to have an or else
okay
okay
um there has to be a Reckoning with
coming clean here
you're you're dangerously close to
losing yourself for good and I don't
want that for you
yeah and what I mean by that is you prop
your feet up and you drop your shoulders
and you say the the the the scariest
words in the English language
it is what it is
and then this just becomes your reality
okay you know what I mean and hey you're
a grown-up you can choose that
I wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
is what it is
but you can choose that moving forward
you can decide that's what it's going to
be
I hope you don't
I hope you don't
I hope you look in the mirror when we
get off this phone and you say I'm worth
way the hell more than this
and I hope you get off the phone you
look in the mirror and say I deserve to
be told the truth I deserved to not
cheated on I deserve to not be married
to some immature [ __ ] who's hiding
money from me who's hiding relationship
stuff who's hiding deep secrets about
his own sexuality maybe I don't know
what he's hiding but it's clearly a deep
well that you haven't been invited to
and you're his wife
and you get invited to those things by
virtue of marriage
and so he can come clean
he can stop his lie addiction to
dishonesty his addiction to thinking
he's better than everybody in his world
that everybody around him is stupid
he can quit that
or he opts out of your relationship
because you're worth more than this
and you know that I don't ever I've got
a rule about saying you should leave
but it's time for real real hard
boundaries in your relationship because
you're worth more than this leading way
way more